Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Andreas Kornmeier, der Mann, der mich dahin gebracht hat, wo ich jetzt bin. Fitnessmann, ich war eine langsame Schnecke und jetzt bin ich eine schnelle Schnecke. Wie passiert das eigentlich, dass aus langsamen Schnecken wie Thomas Müller schnelle Schnecken werden? Wie Thomas Müller. Das wollen wir heute klären in diesem Tribünengespräch. Hallo und herzlich willkommen dazu. Wer mir das erklären soll, das ist Jan-Philipp Hestermann. Jan, servus.
Servus, Max, grüße dich.
Du bist Athletiktrainer beim FC Ingolstadt. Richtig. Kannst du mir erklären, wie man aus langsamen Schnecken schnelle Schnecken machen kann?
Schwierig, weil Felix auch Talent ist und genetisch bestimmt ist. Ich nehme wahrscheinlich jeglichen Mut.
Warum der zweite? Warum nicht der erste? Könnte man nicht auch den Spielern sagen, komm setze ich da ein, 20 Minuten aus Fahrrad bis Profi, kriegst du selber hin. Warum habe ich da ein falsches Bild von Spielern?
Es gibt sicherlich Spieler, die das auch zu Hause machen würden.
Das hört sich ehrlich gesagt noch einem geringen Prozess an.
Es findet ja dann nicht nur das Training statt, es ist ja dann meistens auch noch mal eine Videoanalyse vom Training mit allen gemeinsam und es ist letztendlich so dieser Abschluss der Woche und deswegen finde ich es dann auch gut, wenn die Jungs dann alle beisammen sind, sowohl im Sieg als auch bei einer Niederlage, dass man eben dann auch noch mal gemeinsam das ganze Revue passieren lässt, ich glaube das gehört auch dazu. Ja, deswegen meistens der Tag nach dem Spiel, aktive Regeneration nach der Belastung, das ist ja trainingswissenschaftlich auch nachgewiesen, dass es eben eine gute Wirkung hat und dass eben dann erst der übernächste Tag frei ist und aber das ist natürlich auch individuell, muss man auch sagen, also es gibt sicherlich auch Spieler, die dann eher sagen, boah, eigentlich brauche ich das nicht, ich brauche das lieber jetzt frei und morgen muss ich was machen, aber gut, es ist so in dem Fall, muss sich jeder auch fügen dann, weil es ja eine Mannschaftsportart ist und dann geht es in der Regel am Dienstag weiter, meistens dann auch mit zwei Einheiten, eine davon ist dann Krafttraining und dann haben wir Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag-Training, wenn ich jetzt am Samstag dann wieder spiele und bei uns ist es dann eben so, dass wir viele vor- und nachbereitende Maßnahmen ergreifen, also in erster Linie bin ich dann auch dafür zuständig, dass die Spieler eben vor dem Training kommen, Wir stellen die Jungs dann eben eine Stunde vorher ein, machen mit denen dann ihr Präventionsprogramm, ihre Trainingsvorbereitung. Da achte ich eben schon dann auch drauf, dass gerade jetzt die jüngeren Spieler vielleicht eher kommen oder mal mehr kommen als jetzt ein Spieler, der eben schon länger dabei ist, weil da sind natürlich auch viele dabei, die ihre eigenen Routinen haben. Ein 30-Jähriger oder 31-Jähriger, der weiß ja, was ihm gut tut und die haben ihre Abläufe dann eben auch in der Woche so drin. Aber da geht es dann für mich eher auch darum, die jüngere Generation an die Hand zu nehmen und mit denen dann ihre Programme, welches wir eben anhand von einer Leistungsdiagnostik erstellt haben, durchzuführen. Wir sind dann eben zu zweit oder zu dritt. Meistens ist dann noch ein Physiotherapeut dabei. Und diese Maßnahmen passieren dann im Endeffekt von Mittwoch bis Freitag. Wenn Freitag Abschlusstraining ist, ist dann in der Regel – lassen wir sie Freitag meistens in Ruhe. Weil, ich finde, so ein Tag vor dem Spiel, da soll auch jeder selber für sich entscheiden können, was ihm gut tut. Da sind wir dann meistens eher begleitend dabei. Und unsere Hauptarbeitszeit ist dann eben wirklich von Dienstag bis Donnerstag, in der wir wirklich auch dann viel aktiv eingreifen. Und dann zum Spiel hin wird es in der Regel etwas weniger.
Und wenn du sagst Präventionsprogramm, was meinst du damit? Also ja, vermutlich die Prävention von Verletzungen im Training. Also ist das jetzt einfach nur ein hippes Wort für Aufwärmen? Oder was ist damit gemeint?
Ja, im Prinzip ist es so, dass es eine gute Trainingsvorbereitung ist. Ich glaube, in der heutigen Zeit ist es einfach wichtig, dass du dich entsprechend vorbereitest auf ein intensives Training, weil du hinten raus, umso länger du eben spielst, davon profitieren wirst. Und das ist ja die Schwierigkeit, den Spielern das eben auch zu vermitteln, weil das, was in fünf, sechs Jahren ist, siehst du jetzt ja noch nicht und wirst du womöglich auch nie sehen. Das heißt, wir aktivieren im Endeffekt die Spieler, wir machen mit denen entsprechende vorbereitende Maßnahmen natürlich schon auch immer im Hinblick auf das Training, was dann folgt. Wenn jetzt draußen eben kleine, intensive Spielformen sind, dann versuchen wir natürlich schon in der Trainingsvorbereitung auch entsprechend darauf einzugehen. Trotz allem sind es in der Regel schon auch die Basics, die wir immer wieder abrufen im Bereich Beweglichkeit, Koordination, Stabilität.
Ist jede Muskelverletzung vermeidbar?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass es eben auch sehr viel vom Fasertyp abhängt. Also was für ein Spieler-Typ du bist, also ein Spieler, der sehr schnell kräftig ist, der viele schnelle Muskelfasern hat, der ist einfach anfälliger, wie man jetzt als Beispiel wahrscheinlich Arjen Robben oder Franck Ribery. Das ist halt einfach so. Die sind da einfach der Tonus, also die Spannung auf der Muskulatur ist bei diesen Spielern einfach immer sehr, sehr hoch. Und da ist eben auch die Gefahr, dass es irgendwann mal knallt, größer als vielleicht bei einem Spieler, der da eher vielleicht der ausdauernde Typ ist.
Und wird das untersucht, also kennst du die Faser-Typen deiner Spieler in der Mannschaft? Hast du die irgendwo auf dem Clipboard und kannst sagen, ok, also du heute bitte diese Übung nicht?
Nein, also so weit sind wir jetzt nicht bei uns. Ich glaube, in der DDR hat man das früher gemacht.
Da hat man ja auch noch andere Dinge gemacht.
Aber unter anderem auch das, das machen wir jetzt nicht. Trotzdem wird ja schon im Endeffekt im Vorfeld, bevor der Spieler verpflichtet, wird er drauf geguckt. Ja, jetzt hat er ja eine gewisse Grundschnelligkeit und das sind ja eine Rede, die Außenbahn-Spieler, die da immer doch sehr schnell sind und dann auch dafür in Frage kommen oder eben die Außenstürmer. Von daher kann man das relativ schnell, finde ich schon, irgendwie auch rausfinden.
An diesen Zeiten müsste man das halt zum Beispiel sehen. Das ist jetzt das, was du dann im Profibereich machst und jetzt habt ihr ja dann auch noch U-Mannschaften, du musst ja dann auch noch irgendwann die ganzen Daten verarbeiten, die erfasst werden. Da können wir gleich nur drüber sprechen, was das überhaupt eigentlich alles ist. Ich habe in der Vorbereitung auf dieses Gespräch ganz viele Begriffe zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben gelesen und war mir aber nicht immer sicher, ob das jetzt schlimm ist. Also bei manchen war hatte ich auch das Gefühl, okay, das ist jetzt die englische Bezeichnung von etwas, das ich vielleicht sogar schon gekannt hätte. Aber was machst du denn drum herum um die Trainingseinheiten?
Dokumentieren, viel dokumentieren.
Sind das deine Exit-Tabellen, in die du dann Werte einträgst?
Genau, man hat natürlich entsprechende Systeme mittlerweile, haben wir ja auch. Gerade im Profibereich haben wir ja ein GPS-System, aus dem du die Daten dann auch rausziehen kannst.
Also für die Laufwerte, nicht, dass die Spieler verloren gehen und man sieht, sie waren jetzt irgendwie in der Kneipe, sondern es geht um die Laufwerte, ja?
Es geht um die Laufwerte, ja. Also das andere, da würden wir glaube ich zu weit in die Persönlichkeitrechte eingreifen.
Weil will man das vielleicht auch gar nicht immer wissen.
Nee, nee, nee, sollen ruhig. Sollen ja auch, dürfen wir auch ein Privatleben haben, die Jungs, sollen sie ja auch. Genau, also mein Kollege ist da für ein Ersternier zuständig, der macht die Datenanalyse. Im Prinzip ist das auch ein eigener Bereich. In England ist es oft so, dass sie für diese Bereiche eine eigene Position haben, der nichts anderes macht als Datenanalyse. Diese Daten eben auswertet und zubereitet und dann dem Athletiktrainer oder dem Trainer vorlegt. Das machen wir jetzt aktuell noch selber bzw. mein Kollege Jörg, der ist da sehr affin für die Geschichte und auch sehr, sehr gut. Zieht da, finde ich, gute Erkenntnisse auch raus.
Was sind das für Erkenntnisse, dass man sehen kann, wie fit ein Spieler gerade ist, ob er überlastet ist oder worum geht es da?
Das ist natürlich dann letztendlich die Detailarbeit. Wir haben jetzt das System noch nicht so lange, sondern in Anführungsstrichen erst seit anderthalb Jahren. Da geht es natürlich erst mal am Anfang darum, Daten zu sammeln, dann eben auch zu gucken, was ist ein entsprechender Trainingsload, Wochenload. Über vier Wochen gesehen, wie stellt sich das dar. Da gibt es dann verschiedene Parameter, die zusammenlaufen. Du kannst dann anhand dieser Parameter immer erkennen, wir haben jetzt in der Woche an dem Tag das Trainingsvolumen und die Intensität so und so. Vielleicht eine Woche später, an dem gleichen Tag, war sie deutlich weniger. Woran liegt es? Das sind die Sachen, mit denen du letztendlich rumspielst. Das Ganze kannst du dann auch noch mal für einen einzelnen Spieler machen. Aber das ist schon extrem aufwendig und sehr viel Detailarbeit, was meines Erachtens einer alleine in der Funktion als Athletiktrainer gar nicht leisten kann. Wenn du wirklich da noch tiefer einsteigen möchtest, dann brauchst du da auf Dauer definitiv jemanden, der nur das macht und sich nur damit beschäftigt, um dann noch detaillierter zu arbeiten. Das ist in England schon weit verbreitet. Gerade diese Laufdatengeschichte ist da doch sehr präsent und wird sehr viel mitgearbeitet.
Aber das heißt ja, über die Datenerfassung ist es dann auch nicht mehr möglich, dass ich mich als Spieler irgendwie durch ein Training durchmogel. Oder Stefan Kießling hat irgendwann mal erzählt, dass man bei den Winterpausen Hausaufgaben, die man mitbekommt als Spieler, dass man da dann schon auch manchmal drumrum herkommt, um so zu sagen – oder ich habe auch schon gelesen, dass dann hin und wieder mal angeblich die Uhr kaputt war, die das alles tracken sollte. Ah, okay, das ist schon der Recall der Klassiker. Aber das wird ja dann alles viel mehr zurückgehen jetzt über die modernen Möglichkeiten. So richtig kann man sich im Training nicht mehr einfach immer ganz hinten bei der Übung anstellen und so ein bisschen durchrutschen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber auch da sage ich, es ist eine Hilfe. Und so sollte es auch gesehen werden, auch für den Spieler und nicht als Druckmittel oder als wir beobachten dich jetzt Tag und Nacht, was du machst, sondern es ist eine Hilfe. Es soll letztendlich ja dazu dienen, die Leistung zu optimieren. Und im besten Fall haben wir ja alle was davon. Und ich glaube, das muss man auch immer wieder hervorheben und kein Spieler wird jetzt eine Strafe bekommen, wenn er jetzt mal ein oder zwei Läufe nicht gemacht haben oder die auf der Uhr nicht drauf sind. Ja, ich glaube, da so viel Fingerspitzengefühl hat dann doch auch jeder Trainer und auch jeder Athletiktrainer, dass er da jetzt nicht gleich den Hammer rausholt. Es geht ja nur darum, zu gucken, ob die Jungs in ihren Bereichen trainieren, weil nicht immer ist es so, dass wir jetzt hochintensive Laufeinheiten haben wollen, jetzt beispielsweise in der Übergangsperiode.
Was meinst du mit Übergangsperiode?
Also Übergangsperiode ist im Endeffekt die Zeit zwischen zwei Saisons, also Ende Saison bis zur Trainingsvorbereitung. Das ist die Phase, in der die Spieler ja dann Urlaub haben, in der sie sicherlich auch mal freie Tage oder trainingsfreie Tage haben, aber wenn die Pause eben länger ist und bei uns war sie im letzten Sommer gute sechs Wochen, dann haben die natürlich auch Hausaufgaben und kriegen einen Trainingsplan mit an die Hand und da wird natürlich dann auch geguckt, ob der Trainingsplan entsprechend auch durchgeführt wird. Wie gesagt, da gibt es sicherlich vereinzelt Kandidaten, mit denen wir dann auch mal Probleme haben, aber ein Großteil der Spieler absolviert es und absolviert es auch zu vollsterf Zufriedenheit und die wenigen, die es eben vielleicht nicht machen, machen das auch nicht immer nur aus Schikane, sondern da muss man dann eventuell mal hinterher telefonieren und fragen, was los ist, aber es ist nicht so, dass die das mit Absicht machen. Also von daher ist es eine Hilfe, so sollte es auch gesehen werden und wir wollen alle, glaube ich, die Leistung optimieren und generieren und das sollte auch im Vordergrund stehen.
Okay, kein Druckmittel. Aber sag mir mal, du hast mir jetzt eine normale Woche mit zwei Spielen am Samstag beschrieben. Wie verändert sich das denn, wenn man jetzt unter der Woche auch spielt? Also die berühmte Doppel- Dreifachbelastung. Kann man denn dann im athletischen Bereich überhaupt noch irgendwas machen? Weil wenn du mir sagst, dass die wichtigen Tage Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag sind, dann sind das ja genau die Tage, an denen man dann spielen würde.
In den Wochen passiert da sehr wenig. Da geht es in erster Linie um Regeneration. Regeneration ist ja auch ein Teilbereich, den wir abdecken und mit dem wir uns beschäftigen. Und da geht es dann wirklich in erster Linie darum, die Spieler schnellstmöglich wieder herzustellen. Durch passive Maßnahmen in Form der medizinischen Abteilung und natürlich auch durch aktive Maßnahmen, die wir dann mit den Jungs ergreifen. Aber da wird jetzt kein intensives Training stattfinden oder wir werden jetzt da vor dem Spiel ein Krafttraining ansetzen oder wie auch immer. Das passiert natürlich dann nicht.
Das heißt, bei solchen Mannschaften muss ja dann die athletische Ausdauer, die muss in der Saisonvorbereitung und in der kurzen Winterpause, also Rückrundenvorbereitung, gelegt werden. Also ist es tatsächlich so, dass man in der Saisonvorbereitung in diesen mysteriösen Wochen im Sommer, in denen jeder Fußballfan sich mit Transfers beschäftigt, mit irgendwelchen völlig sinnlosen Testspielen und mit dem Gefühl, wie könnte die nächste Saison werden? Ist es wirklich so, dass in diesen mysteriösen Wochen das gelegt wird, was sich dann am Ende der Saison vielleicht auszahlt?
Also ich sag mal, in den sechs Wochen wirst du nicht alleine den Grundstein für eine erfolgreiche Saison legen, sondern ein Leistungsfußballer trainiert im Prinzip ja das ganze Jahr über. Er hat vielleicht mal eben dann nach der Saison paar freie Tage, aber jemand, der in dem Bereich tätig ist, der viel Sport gemacht hat sein Leben, der wird sich meines Erachtens immer bewegen, er hat immer den Drang, was zu machen. Das heißt, das System steht ja nie still. Deswegen geht in der Regel ja auch dann nicht so viel verloren, gerade wenn die Pause kürzer ist, wenn sie eben länger ist, wird dann ein entsprechender Übergangsplan gemacht, der ja im Prinzip dann auch schon aufbauend ist auf das, was danach folgt. Deswegen ist es dann ja auch eben wichtig, dass die Jungs diese Pläne dann doch schon grundlegend auch einhalten, weil wir in dem Fall jetzt bei uns, haben wir von, glaube ich, drei oder vier Wochen sogar gesprochen, in denen dann dieser Plan eben abgehalten wurde. Und das ist ja dann schon basierend oder das ist die Basis, die da dann gelegt wird, um dann eben in der Trainingsvor- oder Saisonvorbereitung mehr in eine spezielle oder Spezifität einzusteigen, sprich in das Fußballrische. Und das heißt, du hast ja schon eine längere Vorbereitung dann eigentlich als sechs Wochen oder vier Wochen je nachdem. Und dann gibt es ja eben auch nochmal die berühmten Länderspiel-Pausen und da ist natürlich schon auch nochmal die Möglichkeit, das Ganze zu erneuern bzw. auch einen neuen Reiz zu setzen. Das heißt, du musst schon gucken, dass du immer wieder auch nachhaltig arbeitest und auch immer wieder mal in gewissen Bereichen einen Reizpunkt setzt. Und es gibt Spieler, die eben vielleicht im Ausdauerbereich eher Defizite haben, dann gibt es eben Spieler, die mehr im Kraftbereich Defizite haben. Und das kann man dann schon ganz gut mal auch in den Phasen nutzen. Das heißt, du musst immer wieder die Reize erneuern, um dann eben auch dich zu entwickeln und das auch zu erhalten. Jetzt redest du natürlich wahrscheinlich auch von Champions League und so weiter und Länderspiele. Ja, das ist schon eine Herausforderung. Ich muss sagen, Athletiktrainer gerade jetzt bei Bayern München, auch Borussia Dortmund, das ist, glaube ich, nicht so einfach. Das ist schon eine Herausforderung, weil da geht es eben wirklich viel um Regeneration, viel darum, dass die Spieler eben wieder hergestellt werden, schnellstmöglich. Da geht es jetzt weniger um Leistungsentwicklung, sage ich mal, in dem Sinne durch Training, weil du hast ja in der Regel alle drei Tage im Spiel und das ist ja die Hauptbelastung und das ist der Wettkampf und darauf ist alles ausgerichtet. Das ist natürlich dann eben, wenn du jetzt bei uns speizisch weiter arbeitest, einfach einfacher, weil wir nicht diese Anzahl an Spielen haben und dann sicherlich gezielter auch arbeiten können.
Und wie lange braucht man, um eine Mannschaft auf ein Fitnesslevel zu heben, dass man jetzt in der zweiten Bundesliga, in der ersten Bundesliga vielleicht in der dritten, also im Profifußball braucht? Denn immer wieder hört man das ja von Trainern, die eine Mannschaft übernehmen, dass sie sich dann über den Fitnesszustand der Mannschaft beklagen. Und da stelle ich mir jetzt die Frage, okay, bei diesen Mannschaften ist es ja in der Regel dann meistens so, dass die nur ein Spiel pro Woche haben und damit hätte man ja dann die Möglichkeit, an zumindest drei Tagen in der Woche da dran zu arbeiten. Was würdest du sagen aus deiner Erfahrung, wie lange braucht man, um eine Mannschaft auf ein gewisses Level zu heben, mit dem man dann eben diese regelmäßige Belastung er tragen kann?
Also zuerst einmal glaube ich nicht, dass im deutschen Profifußball eine Mannschaft nicht fit ist. Das glaube ich einfach nicht, weil du trainierst täglich. Und jeder Spieler ist ja auch auf einem unterschiedlichen Niveau und dass eine Mannschaft nicht fit ist, würde ja bedeuten, dass jeder Spieler in dieser Mannschaft in allen Bereichen grundlänge Defizite hat und das sehe ich eben nicht so.
Ja gut, vielleicht ist das eine Definitionsfrage. Es gibt ja, also ja, unfit ist natürlich keiner, der Leistungssport betreibt, aber es gibt ja schon immer wieder Mannschaften, wo man sieht, boah, ab der 70. Minute nehmen die Sprints ab, nehmen die intensiven Läufe ab. Also wo man das Gefühl hat, zumindest von außen betrachtet sehen zu können, den gehen hinten raus regelmäßig in den Spielen die Kerne aus.
Ja, das ist aber eben das Gefährliche, dass man eben das versucht, mit bloßem Auge zu analysieren. Dafür müsste man dann mal wirklich die Daten hernehmen. Und da glaube ich schon, dass dann in vielen Fällen das widerlegt werden würde und dass du hinten raus, oder dass Spiele dann vielleicht noch verloren gehen, wenn man 1-0 führt oder 2-1 führt. Und das dann eben an der fehlenden Fitness auszumachen, finde ich, ist auch zu einfach, weil ich glaube, dass viel auch mental dann eine Rolle spielt. Ich glaube, das kann man auch gut analysieren und nachweisen. Viele Mental-Trainer springen ja dann wahrscheinlich auf den Zug auf, dass man dann eher die Angst hat, dann was zu verlieren, anstatt eben aufs Ganze zu gehen und das Spiel zu entscheiden. Von daher glaube ich eher, also das, was ich eben schon mal gesagt hatte, also ich glaube nicht daran, dass eine Mannschaft gerade in der ersten und zweiten Liga nicht fit ist, sondern dass alle ein gewisses Grundniveau haben, um auch 90 Minuten mithalten zu können, dass da eher andere Komponenten eine Rolle spielen. Und wie lange braucht man letztendlich, um so eine Anpassung zu erzwingen, das kann ich dir wirklich nicht beantworten. Also sicherlich, wenn du dein Training grundlegend umstellst und du deutlich intensiver trainierst als vielleicht dein Vorgänger, dann mag es sein, dass du erstmal natürlich in ein Loch fällst, beziehungsweise dass da erstmal was zerstört wird und natürlich dann die Anpassung entsprechend auch vielleicht drei, vier, fünf Wochen dauert. Aber auch da sage ich, puh, schwierig. Weil was ist fit? Definiere mir, was ist fit? Das könnte ich dir jetzt auch nicht sagen. Also was ist für dich fit? Die sind nicht fit. Also es ist für mich dann so, okay, worin sind sie nicht fit? Sind sie in allen Komponenten nicht fit? Glaube ich nicht. Es ist eine ganz, ganz schwierige Definitionsfrage. Oder das zu definieren, finde ich ganz schwierig.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Es ist ein sehr breiter Begriff. Aber wenn wir jetzt im Fußball sprechen, gerade wenn wir jetzt beim deutschen Fußball bleiben, das ist ja ein Umschaltfußball. Es ist wichtig, dass du Umschaltsituationen schnell ausspielen kannst. Sowohl als verteidigende Mannschaft musst du schnell hinter den Ball kommen, als auch als diejenige, die den Ball erobert hat, schnell aufs gegnerische Tor. Und da würde ich dann Fitness definieren, nicht unbedingt in der Anzahl der Sprints, wobei oder intensiver Läufe, wobei das ein Indikator sein kann. Also Leverkusen hat da in der Anfangszeit unter Bosch gefühlt jeden Rekord gebrochen, den es vorher mal in der Bundesliga gab. Jetzt pendet es sich interessanterweise langsam wieder auf einem normalen guten Bundesligadurchschnitt ein. Aber das würde ich jetzt mal als so einen Maßstab heranziehen. Balleroberung in der 92. Minute schafft es die Mannschaft, die den Ball erobert hat, mit fünf Spielern im Vollsprint diese Balleroberung auszuspielen und schafft es die verteidigende Mannschaft schnell noch mal hinter den Ball zu kommen. Das würde ich jetzt mal so als Maßstab nehmen.
Und wenn dann trotzdem ein Tor fällt?
Ich würde es erstmal – ja gut, das ist natürlich klar. Fußball ist ein Ergebnissport und wahrscheinlich guckt man da auch nur drauf, wenn das Tor fällt und man guckt nicht drauf, wenn der Angriff verteidigt wird und zieht dann daraus seine Schlüsse, sondern klar, wir gucken immer besonders auf Tore. Aber ist das nicht so die Definition von Fitness, die am nächsten am Spiel dran ist, dass man sagt, welche Sprintfähigkeit habe ich oder welchen intensiven Lauf kann ich auch noch nehmen, wenn ich eigentlich schon an meiner Belastungsgrenze bin oder wahrscheinlich sogar schon knapp drüber eben in der Nachspielzeit eines Spiels?
Ja, sicherlich kann man die Daten hernehmen und wird ja auch gemacht, dass schon geguckt wird, wie du sagst, wie viel Sprints macht die Mannschaft insgesamt oder auf den einzelnen Positionen, wie viele Meter werden im hochintensiven Bereich zurückgelegt, also eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit. Klar, diese Daten führen wir auch aus, die können wir ja auch letztendlich rausziehen aus dem Datenpool und das wird gemacht, aber es ist natürlich auch ganz klar abhängig von der Spielweise. Und da wird ja dann auch immer bekanntlich, oder es hat ja immer einen Eingang gefunden, dass diese Laufleistung als der Parameter schlechthin genommen wird und das ist es ja, wenn man ehrlich ist, auch nicht, weil, weiß nicht, die Zahlen nicht im Kopf, aber Bayern München mit, unter Beb Gordiola, mit 70, 80 Prozent Ballbesitz wird wahrscheinlich immer weniger Laufleistung gehabt haben als jetzt der Gegner und wenn ich das jetzt als alleiniges Gitarre umher nehme, dann passt es ja nicht ganz zusammen und deswegen finde ich es immer schwierig zu sagen, nur anhand der Laufleistung oder nur anhand von Laufdaten, die sind jetzt fit oder die sind nicht fit oder wie auch immer. Also da muss man schon genauer hingucken, aber klar intensive Läufe, Sprints, wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann dann schon noch die Gesamtdistanz, wenn du natürlich deutlich immer im Schnitt drunterliegst, dann musst du ja schon mal die Frage stellen, woran liegt das. Aber wie gesagt, daran glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube nach wie vor, dass im deutschen Profifußball die Mannschaften alle auf einem sehr guten Grundniveau sind und ja, von daher, okay, würde ich, würde mich mal interessieren natürlich auch was andere unter fit dann auch verstehen, weil wie gesagt der Begriff sehr weit gefächert ist und man dann doch schon, wenn man drüber spricht, ins Detail gehen sollte und fragen müssen, was genau meinst du jetzt damit?
Das wäre natürlich vielleicht auch mal eine Aufgabe für den Journalismus in solchen Fällen. Aber wenn mir jetzt sogar der Athletiktrainer jetzt hier an dieser Stelle schon sagt, lauf Distanz, was soll das eigentlich schon aussagen und ich gleichzeitig aber sehe, das ist so eine Fixierung in der Sportberichterstattung. Also bei manchen Übertragungen, gerade bei großen Turnieren, wo die Tracking Daten live für die übertragenen Sendeanstalten zur Verfügung stehen, da wird das oft bei der Auswendung, Auswechslung noch mal eingeblendet, Distanz covered und dann denkt man sich, ach, 70. Minute, schon 11 Kilometer gelaufen, ist ja unglaublich viel. Dabei kann es ja auch bedeuten, dass dieser Spieler ganz häufig völlig falsch positioniert war und deswegen ganz viele Meter machen musste zusätzlich, als es vielleicht ein Spieler gemacht hätte, der besser antizipiert hätte, was im Spiel passieren wird. Ist das ein deutsches Phänomen, dass wir uns auf diese Laufleistung so konzentrieren?
Nee, es wird ja auch bei internationalen Spielen angezeigt. Von daher ist es, glaube ich, kein rein deutsches Phänomen. Es ist ja auch einfach, den Parameter herzunehmen, weil du hast ja Vergleichswerte. Es ist ja schwieriger, jetzt die einzelnen Spieler in der Berichtserstattung gegeneinander zu stellen. Vereinzelt wird es vielleicht mal gemacht, aber was sagt das dann schon aus? Also ich glaube, das ist wieder dieser Punkt. Man will einen Wert haben, um zu vergleichen und deswegen ist natürlich die Gesamtlaufleistung eben dann wahrscheinlich am einfachsten herzunehmen, um den Zuschauer zu zeigen, pass auf, die Mannschaft Rot ist so und so viel gelaufen, die Mannschaft Blau ist so und so viel gelaufen. Das ist, glaube ich, eher dem geschuldet. Aber wenn man dann wirklich mehr ins Detail gehen würde, dann würde man eben auch merken, dass das jetzt nicht das alleinige Merkmal ist, um zu analysieren, ob jetzt eine Mannschaft auf einem gewissen konditionellen Niveau ist oder nicht.
Ich wünsche mir ja schon ganz lange, dass man sich einfach mal überlegen würde für positionsabhängig, ok, woran kann man den Erfolg eines Spielers dann messen und dann guckt man, ob man da mal irgendwelche Tracking-Methoden einführt und dann eine Vergleichbarkeit herstellt.
Ja, ist ja schon so, wenn du eine Mannschaft hast, die grundsätzlich in der Laufleistung immer bei 100, also das Beispiel jetzt 118 Kilometer läuft und läuft dann auf einmal nur noch 110 über mehrere Spiele, dann macht es natürlich schon Sinn, auch mal da näher hin zu gucken und zu gucken, woran liegt das. Das meine ich ja eben damit. Man muss erst mal Daten sammeln, um dann irgendwann auch vergleichen zu können und dann am besten natürlich auch noch ins Detail gehen und mit den einzelnen Spielern das zu machen. Das ist ja dann die, sag ich mal, Detailarbeit, um die es dann am Ende vielleicht auch geht in dieser Datenanalyse.
Ist das dann nicht fürchterlich frustrierend, wenn man jetzt ein Jahr Daten oder zwei Jahre Daten gesammelt hat bei einem Spieler, man hat endlich Vergleichswerte, man weiß, wie er im November letztes Jahr und im November vorletztes Jahr drauf war und dann wechselt er und man bekommt irgendwie drei neue Spieler. Könntet ihr Athletiktrainer euch nicht alle zusammen tun und euch die Datenpakete, die werden dann beim Transfer mit reinverhandelt und dass man die Vergleichbarkeit hat? Wir ignorieren mal Datenschutz oder sowas.
Ja gut, das musst du in dem Bereich, glaube ich, auch. Ja, es ist sicherlich nicht immer einfach, aber ich finde, dass der Austausch unter den Athletiktrainern schon sehr gut ist, sehr offen auch ist, weil wir ja daran interessiert sind, einfach eben auch diese Dinge weiter zu entwickeln und eben in dem Fall auch Vergleiche zu haben. Was da natürlich die Schwierigkeit ist, dass die Vereine oft mit unterschiedlichen Systemen arbeiten. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt System X hast, kannst du es nicht mit dem System X vergleichen, weil der vielleicht ganz andere Werte bzw. auch der Wert sich dann anders zusammensetzt. Das macht es ein bisschen schwieriger. Von daher wäre es natürlich vielleicht sogar mal ratsam, irgendwann einheitliche Systeme einzuführen, dass alle Bundesligisten mit einem Tracking-System arbeiten. Dann hast du natürlich die Möglichkeit, einfach auch besser untereinander zu vergleichen und womöglich auch für die, für den DFB, für die Nationalmannschaft, dann die Spieler, die eben dorthin fahren, dass man eben dann auch da einen Überblick hat, weil das ja dann oft doch kompatibel ist, dass man die Daten dann eben reinladen kann in sein System. Das wäre sicherlich so etwas, was in der Zukunft eventuell mal kommen könnte und uns auch helfen würde.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man es jetzt eben nicht als Kontrollmechanismus begreift, so wie du es vorhin beschrieben hast, sondern eben den ganzen Bereich der Prävention damit rein nimmt. Und das wäre jetzt auch so ein bisschen der Aspekt, wo ich gerne mit dir hinwollen würde. Denn Athletiktrainers sind ja auch dafür zuständig, Spieler, die sich verletzt haben, in der Reha zu begleiten. Oder wie wird das organisiert?
Also in einem gut organisierten Konstrukt hast du in der Regel auch einen Reha-Trainer, der sich in erster Linie dann um den Spieler kümmert nach seiner OP bzw. sobald er wieder gewisse Bewegungstherapien machen kann. Und der Athletiktrainer kommt für mich dann ins Spiel, wenn gewisse Teilbereiche wieder voll belastbar sind. Also ich finde, das ist schon wichtig auch zu wissen. Natürlich hat ein Athletiktrainer auch das Wissen, um gewisse Rehmaßnahmen zu ergreifen. Aber ich finde schon, dass das zwei unterschiedliche Positionen sind, die ineinander übergehen.
Und das ist auch in den meisten Bundesligisten so organisiert, dass es zwei verschiedene Positionen sind, das ist nicht im Personal Union.
In der ersten Bundesliga ist es meines Wissens gang und gäbe und auch in der zweiten Bundesliga teilweise schon so. Ja, also das sollte auch so sein, weil es eben schon Dinge gibt, die vielleicht ein Reha-Trainer dann doch nicht so machen kann oder auch vielleicht nicht so das Wissen hat. Und der Athletiktrainer, gerade wenn es jetzt um Leistungssteigerung oder Leistung generieren geht, dann vielleicht dann mehr Struktur hat. Das aber auch nicht schlimm ist. Also das ist halt so. Es sind verschiedene Bereiche, die aber ineinander übergehen. Also es gibt sicherlich auch Positionen, wo das in Personalunion ist.
Und jetzt hast du vorhin schon ein bisschen beschrieben, wie man mit Cheftrainern zusammenarbeitet. Du hast aber auch schon angesprochen, dass es ja einen ganzen Pool an verschiedenen Personen im Umkreis einer Bundesliga-Profilmannschaft gibt, die alle so ihren eigenen Bereich haben. Da gehört ja zum Beispiel dann die medizinische Abteilung mit dazu. Wie funktioniert denn die Zusammenarbeit der Athletiktrainer? Jetzt berichte einfach aus deinem Alltag mit der medizinischen Abteilung.
Ja, das sind eben auch Meetings, die dort immer wieder stattfinden. In der Regel auch Anfang der Woche natürlich, um alle Spieler dann einmal kurz durchzugehen, wie der Stand der Dinge ist. Ja, wer womöglich jetzt mal aus dem Training rausgenommen werden muss. Dann geht es eben auch um die Spieler, die im Aufbautraining sind, wie weit sie sind, wann wer übernimmt, was dann auch gemacht wird. Ansonsten ist es auch eine tägliche Absprache, weil vieles ist ja nunmal auch Tagesgeschäft im Fußball. Dann muss man eben schon auch entsprechend täglich auf die Sachen eingehen. Wenn ein Spieler jetzt eben mal vielleicht nicht auf dem Platz trainiert, dann aber eben im Kraftraum was machen kann. Aber in der Regel sind die Mediziner diejenigen, bei denen die Spieler sich melden, die dann auch die Infos weitergeben, die auch uns sagen, was gemacht werden kann.
Und die treffen dann auch die Entscheidung. Also wenn die medizinische Abteilung sagt, keine Belastung auf dem rechten Knie, dann machen wir das.
Ja, sie geben Empfehlungen ab. Am Ende des Tages entscheidet schon meistens der Trainer. Wobei ich das jetzt bei uns so finde, oder dass es bei uns jetzt so gehandhabt, dass die Mediziner dann schon eben auch eine Empfehlung abgeben und das dann auch so gemacht wird.
Okay, aber es gibt quasi keine klare Hierarchie, dass es einfach so ist, dass ein Mediziner dann auch mal das Stoppsignal hebt und sagt, das geht jetzt aus medizinischer Sicht nicht, das sollte ja eigentlich die alles Entscheidende sein, oder?
Ja, aber ich finde, das läuft schon ganz gut, also das wird in der Regel so gemacht. Dafür ist er ja auch da, dafür ist ja auch die medizinische Abteilung bei uns vor allen Dingen auch relativ groß und auch mutbesetzt, dass da eben auch die Kompetenz da ist und auch gegeben ist, wenn dann eben auch gesagt wird, der kann nicht, dass dann eben auch nichts gemacht wird bzw. dass er dann eben auch nicht trainiert. Es ist vielleicht jetzt nicht so ausgesprochen, wenn der das sagt, ist es so, aber es wird in der Regel schon so gemacht.
Sind denn Mediziner immer bei jeder Trainings- und Krafteinheit mit dabei? Kann ja eigentlich fast gar nicht funktionieren, oder?
Also es sind immer ein bis zwei Mediziner oder Physiotherapeuten beim Training dabei und auch beim Spiel. Also beim Spiel sind es zwei und beim Training ist in der Regel immer einer am Platz, aber jetzt bei uns speziell im Kraftraum, bei den Einheimen ist jetzt keiner dabei, ist aber jetzt auch nicht notwendig, außer wir sind eben in der Trainingsvorbereitung, gerade im Bereich Prävention, dann kommt meistens oder kommt immer ein Mediziner mit dazu und wir sind dann zu dritt, sodass wir dann eben auch noch etwas gezielter auf den einen oder anderen eingehen können.
Aber das heißt quasi, du wirst natürlich ein gewisses medizinisches Wissen haben, das hast du ja sicherlich auch in einer Ausbildung, in deinem Studium dir angelernt, aber es muss jetzt keine Nebenkompetenz von dir sein, weil du eben weißt, im Zweifel ist immer noch mal ein Experte mit dabei, der den medizinischen Blick hat.
Genau, also ich bin kein Physiotherapeut und meine medizinischen Kenntnisse reichen auch nicht aus, um da jetzt groß einzugreifen und ich denke, dass der Schuster aber sein Leisten bleiben sollte und ja, so handhabe ich das für mich auch. Ich interessiere mich für den Bereich natürlich, weil wie gesagt, oft ist es ja auch übergreifend, aber im Endeffekt geht es ja dann schon darum, dass die Mediziner versuchen natürlich den Spieler wieder herzustellen und versuchen, das System wieder in die richtige Richtung zu bringen. Bei uns ist es natürlich schon dann so, dass es auch um Training geht und das ist ja immer so ein bisschen dieser Zwiespahl, in dem man sich dann befindet.
Da sitzt man wahrscheinlich öfter mal auf verschiedenen Seiten des Tisches.
Genau und umso besser natürlich die Kommunikation, umso besser auch das Verständnis von beiden Seiten für das andere, umso besser auch die Zusammenarbeit.
Jetzt gibt es gerade im Fußball einen merkwürdig laxen Umgang mit Kopfverletzungen bzw. einfach mit Kopf zusammenstößen, wo sich viele andere Sportarten, in denen das auch vorkommt, gewisse Regeln selbst aufoktroyiert haben, damit man da Risiken von Gehirnerschütterungen und Schlimmerem umgeht. Ich sehe das sehr problematisch, das wird auch im Rasenfunk sehr häufig thematisiert. Deswegen findest du denn auch, dass das ein Problem ist im Fußball?
Mit der Umgangsweise nach so einer Verletzung oder generell?
Ja, vor allem in dem Moment, in dem es passiert. Also einfach, dass das Risiko zu häufig in Kauf genommen wird, ein Spieler nach einem Zusammenprall. Wir kriegen es jetzt eben im Spielen mit. Vielleicht wird es auch im Training passieren, das weiß ich nicht. Den Spieler dann doch nochmal weiter spielen zu lassen, weil er hat ja gesagt, das ist alles gut und er konnte mir sagen, wie viele Finger er gesehen hat und welches Datum ist. Und dann sehen wir aber trotzdem dann in der Folge häufig danach dann wieder Auswechslungen. Zum Teil werden Spieler dann noch mal 20 Minuten weiter spielen und dann bekommt man dann im Nachhinein mit, okay, sie hatten eine Knochenfraktur im Gesicht und das war vielleicht nicht so gut. Es gab jetzt einen Spieler, der kürzlich mal, nachdem er nochmal weiter gespielt hat, dann zusammengebrochen ist auf dem Platz, also wo man sehen kann, aus medizinischer Sicht, ich weiß es jetzt nicht dein Bereich, aber war es nicht die richtige Entscheidung? Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn das in Spielen schon so häufig passiert, dass ich das immer wieder mitbekomme, dann wird das ja wohl im Training mindestens genauso häufig passieren, weil man auch da ja in die Zweikämpfe reingehen muss, wenn man in die erste Mannschaft kommen möchte.
Ja, ich glaube im Training wird deutlich mehr drauf geachtet, wenn ein Spieler oder wenn da so etwas passiert, dann wird in der Regel relativ, oder wird sofort eigentlich dann auch das Training abgebrochen. Also das ist meine Erfahrung bei uns, dass da schon sehr drauf geachtet wird. Im Spiel ist das natürlich dann nochmal wieder eine andere Situation. Wenn es dann auch noch vielleicht ein Spieler ist, der nicht ganz unwichtig ist, da wünscht man sich natürlich dann auch als Trainer, dass man eher drin bleibt und da ist dann in der ganzen Hektik, in der ganzen Aufregung und auch bei dem Spieler selber, der natürlich voller Adrenalin ist, wo vielleicht dann auch die Symptome jetzt erstmal nicht so deutlich da sind. Ich glaube, das kommt auch nochmal hinzu, dass man da in dem Moment auch keine klare Entscheidung treffen kann, vor allen Dingen der Athlet kann keine klare Entscheidung treffen. Dass da viele Sachen dann zusammenkommen und dass dann eben er nochmal gesagt hat, okay, probier es nochmal. Ja, das mag durchaus sein, da ist es sicherlich wichtig, dass dann auch der Mediziner oder in dem Fall auch der Arzt die Kompetenz sein hat, zu sagen, okay, geht nicht mehr raus. Aber wie gesagt, das habe ich jetzt bei uns in der Form noch nicht erlebt, dass da Spieler dann wieder raufgeschickt wurden, die dann im Nachhinein irgendwie Probleme hatten. Aber ja, es gibt es, aber da jetzt das zu verallgemeinern und wer letztendlich dann Schuld daran hat, oh, das ist schwierig.
Nee, es geht mir gar nicht um jetzt Schuld, weil dafür ist es auch einfach ein zu – also man kann das nicht pauschalisieren, das Thema, aber mich würde interessieren, ob das innerhalb der Profifußballvereine inzwischen thematisiert wird, weil meiner Meinung nach tritt es verstärkt auf in den letzten Monaten und man weiß es eben von anderen Sportarten. In der NFL gibt es ein Concussion-Protokoll. Warum gibt es das zum Beispiel im Fußball nicht? Und dann müsste man sich halt eine Lösung überlegen, dass die Mannschaft da nicht die ganze Zeit in Unterzahl spielen muss, dass das höchst ärgerlich ist, dass ein Spieler und jeder der Elfspieler ist ja wichtig für dich, dass der vom Platz runterkommt. Das ist ja völlig klar, aber trotzdem steht ja die Gesundheit des Spielers über dem, dass es ärgerlich ist, ihn zu verlieren.
Gut, das ist so, aber wie gesagt, der Leistungssport ist kein Gesundheitssport und da werden dann eben auch Dinge in Kauf genommen. Der Athlet selber nimmt auch sicherlich Sachen in Kauf, die er vielleicht im Nachhinein, gerade was eben diese Kopfverletzung angeht, auch mit Sicherheit bereuen würde oder wird, sollte es dann Folgeschäden geben. Aber in der Situation selber wirst du das glaube ich sehr selten erleben, dass da ein Spieler vor allen Dingen von sich aus aussagt.
Nee, der Spieler, der ist für mich da, also das ist so, wie wenn ich meine Zwillinge nach der Abendessengestaltung frage. Da nehme ich dann Wohlwollen zur Kenntnis, was sie gesagt haben, aber die Entscheidung trifft dann nicht.
Aber es ist sicherlich so, dass man könnte mit Sicherheit da deutlich intensiver vorgehen. Wir hatten jetzt auch vor kurzem erst einen externen Vortrag aus dem Radsport und die da ja auch ein gewisses System fahren und von daher hatten wir uns da auch schon mit beschäftigt, auch mit gewissen Testings und so weiter, aber das geht dann eher in die medizinische Bereiche rein, die das dann weiterführen.
Jetzt bist du im Bereich, also wir haben schon viel über Regeneration, über Prävention gesprochen und gerade wenn wir in den Bereich vor- und nachspielen gehen, dann stelle ich mir vor, dass es eine Überkreuzung des medizinischen Medaillenbereichs gibt, wenn wir in den Bereich der Schmerzmittel reinkommen. Also man weiß, dass Schmerzmittel viel verwendet werden im Leistungssport. Du hast ja auch schon richtigerweise gesagt, Leistungssport ist kein Gesundheitssport. Welche Rolle spielen denn Schmerzmittel deiner Erfahrung nach im Profifußball und jetzt vor allem in den Tagen, die für dich besonders wichtig sind, bei der Regeneration und dann eben, du musst den Spielern dabei helfen, dass sie quasi sich von der Anstrengung, von der Leistungsspitze des Spiels erholen. Welche Rolle spielen da Schmerzmittel?
Also ich persönlich gebe keinen Rat oder auch keine Schmerzmittel aus oder sage den Jungs, sie müssen jetzt das und das nehmen. Also ich bin absolut ein Verfechter von clean, sage ich jetzt mal so. Ich finde, dass es genügend Maßnahmen gibt, auf natürliche Art und Weise. Felix ist leider auch Routine geworden. Die Aspirin vor dem Spiel oder vor dem Wettkampf, das gehört bei vielen glaube ich dazu, ohne das jetzt zu wissen. Also ich bin zum Glück ja damit auch sehr selten in Konfrontation geraten, weil ich ja auch bei den Spielen beispielsweise gar nicht dabei bin, das macht mein Kollege. Das heißt, ich kriege diese Dinge ja gar nicht so mit, was letztendlich dann auch der Spieler nimmt oder nicht nimmt. Es gibt gewisse fördernde Maßnahmen nach dem Training oder eben auch dann in Regenerationsphasen in Form von Shakes beispielsweise Proteinshakes etc. was sicherlich auch Sinn macht, gerade nach dem Training, um da einfach diese Eiweiß-Synthese auch anzuregen, um diesen Reparaturmechanismus in Gang zu bringen. Aber das ist für mich auch das Maximum, alles andere halte ich für nicht sinnvoll und rate ich auf keinen dazu.
Ich meine, klar, du bist ja auch kein Mediziner, das würden dann die medizinischen Abteilungen beschäftigen, aber siehst du da auch deiner Erfahrung nach jetzt im Profifußball, ist es ein problematischer Umgang mit Schmerzmitteln oder wie würdest du das beurteilen?
Ja, ich glaube schon, ich glaube, dass es deutlich mehr verbreitet ist, als man denkt und wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt wirklich keine Details vor Augen, weil ich da dann vielleicht auch zu weit weg bin oder will ich vielleicht auch zu weit weg sein, aber ich glaube, dass doch sehr viel kaschiert wird damit eben auch mit Schmerzmitteln und dass gerade auch die Karriere hinten raus leiden wird, dass viele Ex-Spieler gerade auch eben aus den 80ern, 90ern, die jetzt eben nicht mehr aktiv sind, dass viele Probleme, die diese Leute jetzt haben, eben möglicherweise auch daher stammen, weil sie eben doch unwahrscheinlich viel mit Schmerzmitteln gearbeitet haben und eben auch im Prinzip ja dann doch auch verletzt gespielt haben oder mit vermeintlich Schmerzen gespielt haben, Ja, ich bin sehr froh, dass wir das jetzt mitbekommen haben, weil letztendlich die Verletzung an sich ist ja nicht weg oder die Entzündung oder keine Ahnung, was was letztendlich dann vorliegt, ist ja nach wie vor da, nur es ist halt betäubt und das ist ja...
Ja, vor allem Schmerz hat ja eine Signalwirkung, also der Körper, der sagt ja nicht, er lässt jetzt nicht den Arm mal schmerzen, einfach aus Jux und Tollerei, sondern der Körper, du sprichst immer vom System, das System signalisiert einem ja damit.
Das ist das Falsche, ja.
Genau.
Ich kriege einen Fehler im System vor und bitte diesen Fehler beheben und da sind Schmerzmittel auf Dauer sicherlich kein Wegbegleiter, gerade im Leistungssport, aber ja, es wird sicherlich sehr oft genommen und aber gut.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei den Simpsons, da gibt es die Folge, da bleibt Tuma mit seinem Auto liegen und sagt, was denn, ich habe doch die ganze Zeit das TESA über den oder das Duct Tape über die Motorleuchte gemacht. So ein bisschen sind da dann Schmerzmittel und da muss man sich nicht wundern. Weil du das jetzt gerade angesprochen hast mit den Langzeitfolgen, die dann ehemalige Fußballer haben, da gab es jetzt gerade auch eine Untersuchung, die bei italienischen Fußballern festgestellt hat, dass die überproportional häufig an der Nervenkrankheit ALS erkranken, die in Verbindung mit gewissen leistungsfördernden Substanzen steht. Ich vermute nicht, dass du mir jetzt hier sagen wirst, es gibt Doping im Fußball und Person XY hat da ABC gemacht. Aber vorhin musste ich daran denken, als es um die Datenerfassung im Fußball ginge. Müsstest du nicht eigentlich oder dein Kollege, der jetzt gerade die Daten einpflegt, müsste man da nicht eigentlich auch Doping erkennen können?
Ich glaube, im Fußball ist es schwierig zu analysieren. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es ausgeschlossen ist, mit Sicherheit nicht. Aber ich frage oder stelle schon die Frage, was genau möchtest du als einzelner Spieler jetzt damit erreichen? Ich glaube, da geht es eher mal um deine körperliche, also um deine eigene körperliche Verfassung.
Klar, wenn ich schneller regeneriere, ist doch alles super.
Genau, darum geht es letztendlich, um zu regenerieren, weil ich sage immer, diese 90 Minuten sind halt trainierbar. Du wirst jetzt anders als im Individualsport, speziell im Radsport oder auch im Marathon, da ist ganz klar, du musst eben diese Wattleistung treten oder diese Zeit laufen, um den Weltrekord oder um die Etappe zu gewinnen. Das hast du ja im Fußball nicht. Das heißt, du müsstest ja dann eventuell ein systematisches Dopingsystem meines Erachtens in der Mannschaft oder in dem Verein haben, dass auch alle das machen und eben dadurch auch ihre Leistung steigern.
Ja, aber kann es ja geben. Also wir wissen zum Beispiel bis heute nicht, wem so mancher Blutbeutel von Fuentes gehört hat und das war sehr, sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich auf Fußball.
Ja, aber trotzdem sage ich eben, dass du diese 90 Minuten trainieren kannst und wenn man sich näher mit dem Doping beschäftigt, dann ist es ja auch so, dass diese Leistungssteigerung erst dann eintritt, wenn du wirklich am absoluten Limit bist. Also wenn du wirklich, sage ich mal, ganz oben bist und wahrscheinlich schon drüber hinaus, dann kommt dieser leistungssteigende Effekt durch beispielsweise Eigenblut, Doping etc. was dann noch alles zugehört, tritt dann erst ein. Das hast du aber meines Erachtens im Fußball nicht, weil kein Spieler an seine absolute Leistungsobergrenze kommt. Und dann geht es für mich eher darum, vielleicht schneller zu regenerieren – okay, das mag sein – das wäre für mich dann aber auch das Hauptargument, das zu tun, dass du eben gerade auch, wenn du eben alle drei Tage ein Spiel hast, versuchst, dich dann eben schnellstmöglich wieder herzustellen und dadurch eben den ganzen Prozess beschleunigst. Aber was natürlich dann auch eine Leistungssteigerung ist, klar, vielleicht zu anderen, aber um deine Leistungsfähigkeit auf dem Platz deutlich zu verbessern gegenüber einem anderen, das finde ich schwierig, weil dafür ist das zu begrenzt. Es ist kein Extremsport, das habe ich schon mal gesagt.
Ja, aber ich weiß es nicht. Also klar, Regeneration ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Wahrscheinlich ist ein zweiter wichtiger Aspekt noch nach einer Verletzung das wieder heranführen an die alte Leistung. Das kann man wahrscheinlich auch sehr gut beschleunigen und ist dann wichtig. Aber gerade weil so viele Komponenten im Fußball zusammenkommen, eben auch die Mentale, die so wichtig ist und wichtiger als in anderen Sportarten vielleicht, kann es doch auch einfach unter diesem Aspekt auch einen Effekt haben. Also wenn ich weiß – ich weiß ja gar nicht, was in der Spritze drin ist oder in der Infusion, die mir da mein Arzt legt, auch wenn ich vielleicht wissen sollte, dass Infusionen schon mal ein Wahnsignal sind. Ich glaube, es ist generell erst mal nicht erlaubt im Leistungssport. Aber wenn ich weiß, ich fühle mich danach immer super. Ich gehe aufs Feld und ich habe einfach ein gutes Gefühl und alle meine Mannschaftskameraden, bei denen ist ganz ähnlich und wir gehen alle mit einem guten Gefühl drauf und wir wissen, allein das kann ja schon genügend Effekt sein.
Ja, gibt es ja auch. Ich habe mich sehr intensiv mit dem Thema Doping beschäftigt und auch viel recherchiert, gerade im Bereich Radsport. Ich habe auch interessante Geschichten gelesen, eben auch über sogenannten Placebo-Effekte, was dann auch geholfen hat. Ja, mag auch alles sein und wird es womöglich auch im Fußball geben, dass der eine oder andere auf irgendeine Sache schwört, die er jedes Mal vor dem Spiel einnimmt. Und der Meinung ist, dass er dann eben schneller und mehr läuft.
Ich würde sogar sagen, das gibt es im Fußball. Ich glaube nicht, wird es wohl im Fußball geben. Dafür gibt es genügend Dopingfälle. Es werden sehr wenige kommen ans Licht, wenn man sich dann allerdings mit der Art, der Testverfahren beschäftigt und das vergleicht, dann sieht man, dass sich zwar Profifußballer gegängelt fühlen, weil sie ihren Wohnort oder weil sie ihren Aufenthaltsort angeben müssen und so weiter. Aber dass die eigentliche Testrate doch erschreckend niedrig ist. Aber wenn wir gerade über Regeneration sprechen und ich mir ansehe, dass in Spanien, in England die Profifußballer zum Beispiel noch viel, viel mehr Spiele machen und aber dort bei manchen Mannschaften wesentlich weniger rotiert wird, als jetzt hier in der Bundesliga, also dann weiß ich immer gar nicht, ist das jetzt eine unterschiedliche Auffassung von Sport, dass das manchmal in Deutschland auf diese Dreifachbelastung sofort hingewiesen wird. Also auch ein gutes Beispiel, Leipzig und Augsburg spielen unter der Woche jetzt 120 Minuten im DFB-Pokal. Damit wisst ihr jetzt auch, wann wir das hier aufgenommen haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Am Wochenende drauf spielen beide wieder, drei Tage später. Und bei beiden Mannschaften wird thematisiert, ja sie mussten ja 120 Minuten spielen im Pokal. Dabei war das einmal. Und klar kann das sein, dass die dann irgendwie nochmal 2% fehlen in der 95. Minute. Aber eigentlich müsste es doch bei diesem einmaligen innerhalb von drei Tagen oder vier Tagen zwei Spiele machen. Muss das doch eigentlich noch drin sein als Leistungssportler? Und in englischen Medien, die würden lachen über so eine Argumentation.
Ja, ist ja auch drin. Ich glaube, das sind ja eher die Medien oder die außenrum, die das dann in Frage stellen bzw. die da Argumente suchen. Ich glaube, das ist in England normal. Also ich glaube, der Körper passt sich ja auch an. Also wenn du das einfach gewohnt bist, einem 38 oder ich glaube, in der zweiten Liga sind es sogar über 40 Spiele zu machen und du eben auch einen gewissen Zeitraum in dieser Liga schon spielst, dann passt du dich ja auch an. Deswegen sage ich ja, es ist aus meiner Sicht trainierbar. Es ist trainierbar, das auszuhalten. Du fühlst dich natürlich nicht immer gleich und es gibt sicherlich auch mal eine Phase in der Saison, wo du einfach einen Hänger hast und du eben vielleicht auch mehr darauf achten musst, dass du eben besser oder Intensität auch rausnimmst und regenerierst. Aber ich bleibe dabei, das ist trainierbar und ein Spieler, der jetzt aus Deutschland dahingeht, der wird sicherlich auch seine Anpassungsprobleme haben am Anfang, aber der wird sich dann auch relativ schnell einfinden und von daher glaube ich, dass das alles machbar ist, auch eben ohne entsprechende zusätzliche nicht erlaubte Maßnahmen.
Wie hättest du dich dann eigentlich auf dem Laufenden? Denn ich habe den Bereich, das ist ja vorhin auch schon gesagt, also vor einiger Zeit schon hast du gesagt, dass immer wieder neue Erkenntnisse mit dazu kommen. Das ist ein relativ junger wissenschaftlicher Bereich, in dem sehr viel noch geforscht wird. Wie schaffst du es neben deinem Alltag da auch noch aktuelle Erkenntnisse mitzunehmen?
In erster Linie durch den Austausch mit anderen Kollegen, die man ja dann doch mittlerweile auch hat und man ist dann doch auch gut vernetzt.
Ist man da auch offen miteinander? Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel rausfinde, dass links drehende Joghurt um 7.15 Uhr am Spieltag 10 Prozent mehr Sprintfähigkeit gibt, dann würde ich das ja nicht gleich verraten.
Doch, ich finde, dass meine Generation, der hat ledig Trainer, von denen kann ich ja auch nur sprechen, doch sehr offen sind und wir uns da doch sehr rege austauschen und das merkt man eben dann auch, wenn man wirklich mal so ein Treffen hat, dass die Pausen doch immer viel zu kurz sind und man aufeinander zustürmt und eben dann oft auch wissen wir, Mensch, wie läuft das bei euch und klar ist es so, dass wir immer wieder auch die gleichen Themen alle haben.
Was sind das so zum Beispiel?
Ja, die Zusammenarbeit natürlich mit dem Cheftrainer. Wer hat wie viel Zeit, wann wird was gemacht, wie läuft die Zusammenarbeit mit der medizinischen Abteilung, wer übernimmt wann, wie sieht das System aus, was macht ihr beispielsweise, was ist Feucht-Kraft-Training, was für im Ausdauerbereich, was wird da gemacht, welche Läufe, warum, weshalb, also solche Themen sind dann schon da und da lernt man dann ja eben auch für sich selber schon viel und wird manchmal auch bestätigt und denkt dann Menschen, ja okay, gut, vielleicht bei RB Leipzig ist es genauso wie bei uns und es beruhigt einen dann wieder. Und ja, dann natürlich durch Fortbildungen, durch Lesen, wissenschaftliche, trainingswissenschaftliche Zeitungen und aber auch Social Media, muss ich schon sagen. Also ich bin selber jetzt nicht wirklich aktiv, aber ich nutze in erster Linie diese Kanäle schon für meinen Beruf und um eben da auch up-to-date zu bleiben und da gibt es auch immer wieder mal Dinge, die man mitnehmen kann. Also es ist nicht nur in Anführungsstrichen verschwendete Zeit, sich auf diesen Kanälen zu begnügen, sondern ich nutze es wirklich in erster Linie, um mich beruflich und fachlich da auch weiterzubilden oder was rauszuziehen.
Okay, das heißt, es gibt irgendwo eine Instagram-Filterblase, in der ich nicht bin, in der man trainingswissenschaftliche Methoden in den Stories sehen kann oder sind es dann eher andere Netzwerke?
Es sind eher andere Netzwerke. Die Übung allein macht es ja nicht aus. Ich finde, da sollte man dann schon mehr ins Detail gehen. Ich sage immer, ob du jetzt den Spieler links oder rechts rumlaufen lässt, ist jetzt nicht entscheidend, sondern da geht es dann eher um Intensität, um Volumen, um was willst du mit dem Training erreichen, was ist das Ziel des ganzen? Solche Themen beschäftigen mich eher als jetzt mir Übungen irgendwo rauszusuchen. Was ich auch mache, gar keine Frage. Es ist ja auch immer mal schön, auch anderen Input zu bekommen, auch was die Ausführungen angeht. Aber die wirklichen Inhalte oder das, worauf es ankommt, für mich, die siehst du jetzt ja meistens nicht an der Oberfläche.
Ich habe gelesen, dass man früher eher einzelne Körperteile trainiert hat. Heute ginge es aber eher um Bewegungsmuster, da vieles Neuronalabläufe.
Neuronale Ansteuerung, ja. Es geht um das Nervensystem. Neuronale Ansteuerung ist über das Nervensystem die entsprechenden Muskelgruppen oder die Bewegungsabläufe in die richtige Funktion zu bringen. Man hat früher eher lokal, also sprich bestimmte Muskelgruppen auftrainiert. Oder was heißt früher, das macht man jetzt ja immer noch. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man es gar nicht mehr macht. Gerade im Reha-Training ist es ja schon eine Sache, die auch sinnvoll ist.
Klar, wenn die Badenmuskulatur weg ist nach der Verletzung, dann brauche ich erst mal die wieder.
Genau, deswegen macht das ja dann auch Sinn zugegebener Zeit. Aber insgesamt wird natürlich schon geguckt, dass wir ja funktionell heißt es ja mittlerweile, oder wird ja immer wieder genannt, der Begriff trainiert. Sportler spezifisch, das heißt, man versucht schon so möglichst spielnah oder bewegungsnah zu trainieren, wie sich der Spieler dann eben auch bewegt auf dem Platz.
Und das macht man eben, weil sich das Nervensystem dann an das Bewegungsmuster erinnert und man das eben eintrainiert, damit es dann im Wettkampf auch abgerufen wird.
Genau, es ist ja im Endeffekt wird der abgespeichert, wie bei jedem Menschen. Bewegungsmuster werden abgespeichert und müssen aber eben auch trainiert werden und sollten dann natürlich im Optimalfall auch dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, in der Perfektion abgerufen werden. Und darum geht es letztendlich, das zu trainieren, eins zu studieren und das ist ja eben auch Training, immer wiederkehrende Dinge zu machen, um das eben zu optimieren. Und das gilt ja nicht nur für den Athletikbereich, sondern es ist ja auf dem Platz genau das gleiche, was das Technische anbelangt mit Passspiel, mit im Endeffekt über hohe Wiederholungszahlen und so geht es ja im Athletikbereich dann eben auch, dass du Bewegungsmuster einstudierst, verfinerst, optimierst, um dann eben auf dem Platz das Ganze auch in der Endausführung so abzurufen, dass es dich auch weiterbringt oder vor allen Dingen, dass du eben auch dich nicht verletzt. Weil ich sagte ja eben schon, dass Prävention ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt, glaube ich, ist in unserem Bereich.
Und ist das dann auch das, wo sich das moderne Fußballtraining ein bisschen vom Althergebrachten unterscheidet? Also es gibt vom Pep Guardiola zum Beispiel die Geschichte, der lässt der Sophie wie möglich nur mit dem Ball trainieren. Das kommt ja auch aus dieser spanischen Schule. Und da gibt es die Geschichte, als er hier nach München kam, dass nach den ersten Trainingsanheiten im Sommer ihn ein paar Spieler wie Franck Ribéry und noch ein paar andere gebeten hätten, ob sie nach dem Spiel noch einen Waldlauf machen dürften. Und da hat das ihn erlaubt und hat aber zu seinen Co-Traineren gesagt, die werden schon noch merken, dass wir genauso viel gelaufen sind, wie normalerweise und sie das jetzt eigentlich nicht gebraucht hätten. Also ist das dann der Unterschied zwischen etwas älteren Training und dem moderneren Training?
Würde ich nicht sagen, es gibt kein älteres und neueres Training, es gibt auch kein Gut und kein Schlecht für mich in diesen Bereichen, sondern das ist eine Philosophie, eine Ansatzweise, die jeder Trainer hat. Und wenn er damit gut fährt, dann ist es ja auch völlig in Ordnung, dass so zu Hand haben und meistens, es sieht ja sein Trainerstab dann auch entsprechend aus und die das ja dann auch unterstützen, also sprich der Pep Guardiola hat ja letztendlich auch sein Team seit Jahren beisammen und die haben das ja letztendlich dann auch so aufeinander abgestimmt und dass der Athletiktrainer ja im Endeffekt diese Philosophie mit Sicherheit auch mitträgt, klar, sonst wäre er nicht mehr dabei.
Und dann gibt es aber auch wiederum andere Vorstellungen oder andere Philosophien, die sagen, okay, nur übers spielerische und nur über Übung mit Ball wirst du gewisse Bereiche nicht weiter entwickeln, dementsprechend müssen wir da auch ohne Ball arbeiten und aber gibt es da noch so unterschiedliche Philosophien also oder hat sich das alles aneinander angeglichen und ist es Zufall, dass jetzt so jemanden wie Felix Magath, der eben immer dieses Quälix-Image hatte und den Hügel der Leiden und bei dem das auch ein bisschen zelebriert wurde, er hat das auch zum Teil selbst gemacht, aber einen solchen Trainer würde ich jetzt gerade im Profifußball gar nicht sehen, der dafür bekannt ist, dass er eben besonders hart trainieren lässt. Ist das eine neue Denke, die da Einzug gehalten hat und deswegen machen alle mit unterschiedlichen Schwerpunkten im Grunde ein ähnliches Programm oder ist es jetzt einfach Zufall, dass eben gerade solche Trainer nicht gefragt sind?
Also die Inhalte haben sich meines Erachtens nicht verändert. Ich glaube nach wie vor, dass wir...
Es gibt noch Medizinbälle im Profifußball.
Also die Inhalte sind meines Erachtens in den meisten oder in vielen Vereinen ähnlich oder gleich. Nur sie werden eben dann anders verpackt oder werden anders periodisiert oder wie auch immer. Aber dass sich da jetzt so grundlegend was verändert, finde ich nicht. Und ich glaube auch selbst ein Felix Magath entwickelt sich ja weiter und der ganze trainingswissenschaftliche Prozess ist ja dynamisch. Ist ja nicht so, dass er nicht in Stein gemeißelt, sondern es gibt ja eben Dinge, die sich dann auch entwickeln. Und ich glaube, dass ein – oder denke mal, dass womöglich ein Felix Magath auch seine Schlüsse aus den Stationen, die er trainiert hat, genommen hat und entsprechend angepasst hat. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es nur das eine oder das andere gibt, sondern irgendwie ist dann doch alles ähnlich, nur jeder hat halt seine unterschiedlichen Vorstellungen und versucht die eben dann für sich so in einen Einklang zu bringen, dass es für ihn passt. Und ich habe das jetzt ja auch in diesem Jahr erleben dürfen mit dem einen oder anderen Trainer, den wir jetzt hatten. Und da ist es ja so, der eine sagt halt eben, er möchte es so haben, der andere sagt, er möchte es so haben. Aber oft sind es trotzdem die gleichen Inhalte, nur eben dann anders miteinander gereiht oder in einer anderen Form.
Gut, das, was man braucht im Fußball, das hat sich ja auch nicht verändert. Jetzt haben wir vorhin schon einen Bereich kurz gestreift, nämlich die Technik. Und ich habe gelesen, zum Beispiel bei Hertha BSC ist es so, schon nach dem Aufstehen geben die Spieler in der App an, wie sie geschlafen haben und sie sich fühlen. In der Kabine wird dann die Herzratenvariabilität gemessen, da darfst du mir gleich erklären, was das ist, die dann Auskunft darüber gibt, wie das Training des Vortags verkraftet wurde. Und bei Bedarf erfolgt dann Blutabnahmen und persönliche Gespräche. Welche Rolle spielt denn Technik in deinem Beruf?
In meinem Beruf die Technik, ja man nutzt sie, aber für mich ist immer noch das Entscheidende, mit dem Athleten selber zu arbeiten. Darüber geht für mich nichts, der persönliche Kontakt. Und ja, es gibt diese Apps und die haben wir ja mittlerweile auch in erster Linie. Aber machen wir das gerade im Jugendbereich, um die Belastung zu erfassen. Wir lassen eben die Jungs das Training einschätzen, um eben dann auch für uns einen Rückschluss zu ziehen aufs Training. Das ist meines Erachtens schon eine sehr sinnvolle Sache und ist auch nicht neu.
Hast du dich dann auch nicht anonymisiert oder seht ihr dann, der hat dem Training die Sieben gegeben? Weil dann werde ich ja immer so tun, als wäre es ein mega easy Training für mich gewesen, einfach nur um zu symbolisieren, hey, ich bin Topfit-Trainer, ich möchte spielen.
Ja, das ist nicht anonym, weil sonst macht es ja keinen Sinn, sondern die Jungs bekommen eben nach ihrem Training dann eine Nachricht, in der sie eben die Trainingsintensität von eins bis sechs angeben müssen und wenn sie natürlich da jetzt das angeben, was vielleicht gar nicht der Wahrheit entspricht, dann schneiden sie sich meines Erachtens ja ins eigene Fleisch. Das ist aber etwas, was man vorher kommunizieren muss, dass das keine Auswirkungen auf das Wochenende hat und ob der Spieler jetzt spielt oder nicht spielt, sondern es geht einfach darum, herauszufinden, wie jeder Spieler für sich diese Einheit empfunden hat und meistens ist es aber schon so, dass man als Trainer ein Gefühl dafür hat und auch abschätzen kann, ungefähr wie hoch die Belastung jetzt in dieser Einheit war. Also wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen eine Einheit haben zwischen fünf und sechs, dann ist das meistens auch deckungsgleich. Und wenn jemand jetzt dann immer eine Dreieinträgt, weil er meint, er ist topfit und er will jetzt unbedingt spielen am Wochenende, dann ist es ja auch so wie eben mit den Daten über so ein Tracking-System, dann geht man natürlich auch mal hin und fragt nach, wie das sein kann oder ist es wirklich so. Aber wie gesagt, das ist eine Kommunikation am Anfang der Sache und ich finde, dass auch das eben wieder ein Hilfsmittel ist und so muss man den Jungs das eben auch verkaufen und auch immer wieder sagen, dass man nicht schikanieren möchte oder dass man nicht den Kontrollwahn hier hat, sondern dass es eben wirklich darum geht, das Training zu optimieren.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt, den persönlichen Umgang mit den Spieler ersetzt Technik natürlich nicht, das hätte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht erwartet. Aber wie sehr hat denn das jetzt zugenommen in den letzten Jahren, dass es eben diese Apps gibt, dass es neue Möglichkeiten des Trackings gibt? Ich meine, dieses GPS-Tracking während des Trainings, das gibt es jetzt schon länger. Aber ich sage mal so, der gute alte Laktat-Test, der wirkt fast schon ein bisschen verstaubt, wenn ich mir angucke, dass jetzt die Herzratenvariabilität gemessen wird.
Ja, also man muss ja da unterscheiden. Also es gibt ja eben diese Herz… Herzratenvariabilität. Da geht es ja in erster Nähe darum, zu gucken, wie die Regenerationsfähigkeit des Spielers ist.
Also Unterschied zwischen Ruhe und Belastungspuls?
Ja, genau, der Abstand zwischen den einzelnen Herzschlägen. Wie schnell das ist, wie hoch der ist. Und daraus erkennt man dann eben beispielsweise, ob ein Spieler jetzt gut regeneriert hat nach einer Einheit oder eben weniger gut regeneriert hat. Und diesen Parameter nimmt man dann eben her, um zu gucken oder vielleicht womöglich auch dann das Training am nächsten Tag zu steuern. Was aber in der Regel schwierig ist, finde ich, weil eben da auch wieder unwahrscheinlich viel erstmal gesammelt werden muss, um zu gucken, was ist überhaupt dein Baseline wert. Und dann musst du ja am Endeffekt jeden Tag das kontrollieren und dann auch eventuell mal irgendwann einzugreifen, wenn der Wert vielleicht über mehrere Tage nicht so ist, wie er vielleicht sein sollte. Aber ich glaube, das finde ich unheimlich aufwendig und schwierig. Es ist gut, wenn man es macht, wenn man auch die entsprechenden personellen Möglichkeiten hat. Ich persönlich bin ehrlich, ich kann es gar nicht abdecken, weil das, finde ich, sehr aufwendig ist. Wir haben es in der Saisonvorbereitung gemacht und dann hatten wir aber auch Probleme wiederum mit den Daten. Dann ist es eben auch so gewesen, dass wir die Spieler vor dem Training getestet haben. Die mussten sich dann beispielsweise alle im Kraftraum versammeln, hinlegen. Dann ist es aber auch so, dass auf dem Weg vielleicht der eine oder andere schon etwas erlebt hat oder womöglich mal etwas Stress hatte mit seiner Frau daheim. Das heißt, du bist da schon wieder im ganz anderen Rhythmus drin und das hat ja dann auch Auswirkungen. Von daher müsste jeder Spieler das dann auch direkt nach dem Aufstehen machen. Das ist natürlich das zu kontrollieren und dann am Ende auch dahinterher zu sein. Dann geht es auch wieder, finde ich, in die Privatsphäre. Das ist alles immer nicht so einfach, wie sich das anhört. Wenn das dann funktioniert, ist es toll und man kann das gerne auch hernehmen. Aber ich finde, im Mannschaftssport ist es schon ein größeres Thema und sollte eigentlich im Optimalfall auch von einem, sage ich mal, vollführt werden und nicht der Athletiktrainer ist dann doch eher für die Praxis zuständig.
Also ähnlich wie es dann in England eher schon der Fall ist, wie du es vorhin beschrieben hast. Jetzt haben wir schon darüber gesprochen, wie deine Zusammenarbeit mit dem Cheftrainer logischerweise funktioniert, wie die Zusammenarbeit mit der medizinischen Abteilung funktioniert. Wie ist es denn mit dem ganzen Bereich Ernährung? Als Athletiktrainer hast du ja mehr mit den Spielern zu tun als so manch anderer, gibst ihnen viele Tipps wahrscheinlich auch für Dinge, die sie eben auch mal außerhalb der Trainingszeiten machen können, die ihrem Körper gut tun. Welche Rolle spielt da Ernährung?
Ernährung spielt mittlerweile sicherlich eine wichtige Rolle, weil die Spieler sich auch selber damit beschäftigen. Das ist jetzt meine Erfahrung und natürlich viele Fragen dann auch haben an uns bzw. auch an die medizinische Abteilung, die jetzt bei uns mehr oder minder dafür zuständig ist, die eben auch entsprechende Pläne an die Hotels gibt, was eben gegessen werden sollte beziehungsweise was eben vor und nach dem Spiel auch da sein sollte. Ist aber auch ein eigener Bereich, finde ich. Auch da wieder, wenn man das richtig aufziehen möchte, ist es ein eigener Themenbereich mit einem eigenen Experten. Das Wissen, was ich jetzt speziell habe, ist ja ich würde nicht sagen Halbwissen, aber bis zu einem gewissen Maß reicht es aus. Aber um jetzt eine Analyse mit einem Spieler tiefgehend zu machen, da sehe ich mich jetzt auch nicht. Aber ich kann natürlich schon gewisse Tipps auch geben, aber wie gesagt, wenn man das richtig aufziehen möchte, dann gehört ein Ernährungsberater für mich auch in so einem Performance-Team, in dem eben auch Athletiktrainer, Reha-Trainer und dann eben auch der Ernährungsberater drin ist.
Und das ist jetzt aber in Ingolstadt noch nicht der Fall?
Nein, wir haben das aktuell nicht. Wie gesagt, wir haben die medizinische Abteilung, die sich da sehr mit beschäftigt, die darauf achtet, dass eben gewisse Dinge auch da sind vor nach dem Training und dass eben in den Hotels an Spieltagen und im Trainingslager entsprechend auch darauf geachtet wird, was dort hingestellt wird und was es eben auch zu essen gibt.
Okay, also haben wir medizinische Abteilung, wir haben jetzt den Ernährungsbereich, oft noch in der Personalunion, in der Idealen Welt. Natürlich hätte man da für alles eine eigene Person. Was ist denn mit dem Bereich der Psychologie, der ja auch so eine große Rolle spielt, auch in unserem Gespräch hat der ja schon eine große Rolle gespielt?
Ja, ich glaube der Kopf ist am Ende wahrscheinlich das entscheidende Merkmal im Hochleistungssport. Da wird viel, glaube ich, entschieden und das ist ja ein Bereich, der gerade auch im Nachwuchsbereich Einkehr gefunden hat. Also es ist ja auch meines Wissens Pflicht, dass du in einem Nachwuchsleistungszentrum der 1. und 2. Bundesliga einen Sportpädagogen oder eben Mentaltrainer, wie auch immer man das denn nennt, hat. Du musst glaube ich keinen Hauptamtlichen haben, weil du musst zumindest jemanden haben, was auch sicherlich sinnvoll ist und was auch bei uns genutzt wird, auch von den Spielern. Sowohl individuell, also einzeln, aber auch eben in Gruppenfunktion. Und am Ende des Tages ist das, was ich dir vorhin schon sagte. Ich arbeite letztendlich täglich mit dem Athleten oder mit dem Spieler zusammen und vieles läuft natürlich eben auch auf der persönlichen Ebene. Und da findest du ja schon irgendwann auch raus, was welcher Spieler braucht, wie du mit ihm umzugehen hast, wie du ihn zu coachen hast. Das sind ja alles mentale Aspekte. Mancher Spieler braucht eben vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Feuer, der muss ein bisschen aggressiver angepackt werden, um dann eben auch die Übung oder auch auf dem Platz entsprechend abzurufen. Dann gibt es eben welche, die vielleicht etwas labiler sind, die musste vielleicht etwas sanfter anfassen. Das sind auch Aspekte, die natürlich als Athletiktrainer extrem wichtig sind, die persönliche Beziehung zu dem Spieler, zu dem Athleten. Und sich da auch mit zu beschäftigen, wie sieht das Umfeld des Spielers aus, was macht er vielleicht in seiner Freizeit, was macht er gerne. Ich glaube, das sind alles so Sachen, die sind sehr wichtig und werden manchmal vernachlässigt. Ich merke das ja selber bei mir auch. Du bist dann oft in deinem Trott drin. Aber da muss man sich immer wieder dran erinnern, hey, es geht hier auch um die Menschen. Es sind keine Maschinen in Anführungsstrichen. Und jeder Tag ist anders. Du fühlst dich nicht immer gleich. Wir reden immer von Regelmäßigkeit, von Kontinuität, von Ehrgeiz, von Fokus. Aber das gilt ja für einen selber auch. Wir haben ja auch nicht immer – nicht jeder Tag bei uns ist gleich. Und das sind ja auch Tage, an denen ich vielleicht nicht so gut drauf bin. Aber trotzdem muss ich dem Athleten gegenüber ja fair bleiben und jetzt nicht aggressiver sein vielleicht als gestern, weil ich gestern gut drauf war. Und das sind so Sachen, da spielt die mentale Ebene oder die psychologische Ebene natürlich eine extrem wichtige Rolle.
Und war das dann auch Bestandteil deines Studiums, dass man sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat? Denn das – also wir reden jetzt, wir streifen jetzt immer wieder so Bereiche. Medizin, Ernährung, jetzt Psychologie – das sind ja für sich genommen schon mal wieder riesige Themenbereiche. Und natürlich ist es nicht deine Aufgabe, dich in allem – kannst du nicht Experte sein – und trotzdem hat alles auch irgendwie mit deinem Gegenstand der Arbeit zu tun.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das macht es ja auch schwierig und interessant zugleich, dass du dich im Endeffekt mit allen Bereichen auseinandersetzen musst. Ich glaube, es ist für mich oder ich denke, es ist immer wichtig, dass du dir vor einem Training auch die Frage stellst, was ist das Ziel des Ganzen heute. Dann eben aber auch berücksichtigst – und das kommt ja auch immer wieder vor, gerade im Einzeltraining – dass der Spieler dann kommt und im Prinzip einfach an dem Tag nicht auf dem Niveau ist, auch vom Kopf her, dass du das mit ihm machen kannst. Dann ist es eben auch deine Pflicht als Athletiktrainer darauf einzugehen und dein Programm dementsprechend umzuwerfen. Oft sitzt du natürlich vorher da, machst dir Gedanken und dann kommt der Athlet und dann ist es so, dass es vielleicht was ganz anderes machen muss, weil er einfach nicht aufnahmefähig ist. Dann kommen wir ja in diese Bereiche wieder mental, dann redest du vielleicht über die Ernährung, hat sich schlecht ernährt. Das sind alles so Sachen, die kommen dann zusammen. Das heißt, ja, du musst schon irgendwie von allem etwas wissen, aber ich finde es auch wichtig zu erkennen, wann du auch sagen musst, ok, bis hierhin, ab dem Punkt bin ich jetzt nicht mehr dein Ansprechpartner, weil da kann ich dir jetzt nicht weiterhelfen. Ich glaube, dass das oft dann verwässert und das ist eben, finde ich, auch die Gefahr über die Social-Media-Kanäle, dass vieles ineinander übergeht und verwässert und das ist meines Erachtens gerade im Leistungssport gefährlich, weil, wie ich eben sagte, Schuster bleibt am Ende leisten, jeder hat ja eine Qualität, jeder kann etwas sehr gut, deswegen arbeitet er da und das muss er auch gut ausführen und wenn es dann um andere Bereiche reingeht, finde ich es ist auch wichtig, dann zu sagen, ok, pass auf, da kann ich dir jetzt gerade nicht weiterhelfen, geh dann bitte dahin oder hole dir den Rad da.
Muss man halt uneitel für sein?
Man muss sich selber zurückstellen, weil du eben nicht im Vordergrund stehst, du bist ein Berater, du bist ein Berater in diesem ganzen Konstrukt, du bist keiner, der eine Entscheidung trifft, das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig. Ein Athletiktrainer ist keiner, der am Ende sagt, so und so wird es gemacht, sondern du bist beratend tätig, du kannst dem Cheftrainer sagen, aus deiner Sicht würdest du heute das und das machen in dem und dem Bereich, ob das am Ende dann gemacht wird, ist aber Sache des Cheftrainers und so ist es ja im Athleten genau so. Du kannst dem Athleten sagen, ich würde heute nach dem Training das und das machen, an regenerativen Maßnahmen, ob der Athlet das dann aber macht, weiß ich nicht. Das muss man wissen und dann muss man auch klarkommen und das kann mitunter sehr anstrengend sein.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Jetzt habe ich gelesen, es gibt einen Athletiktrainer, der bisher in China, Ungarn und der Türkei unter anderem im Einsatz war, Thomas Mohr heißt der, der hat jetzt gerade ganz aktuell das Training von Dieter Hecking und Pardai kritisiert. Er sagt, dass der Einbruch von beiden Mannschaften jetzt bei Hertha WSC und bei Borussia Mönchengladbach in der Rückrunde, den es jetzt schon regelmäßiger zu beobachten gab, auf falsches Training zurückzuführen sei. Jetzt mal unabhängig von der Frage, ob man das aus der Ferne überhaupt beurteilen kann, wo ich große Zweifel habe und das könnte auch nur eine sehr gute PR-Strategie gewesen sein, interessiert mich aber die Frage, ist das überhaupt möglich, dass man so falsch trainiert, so überbelastet im Training, dass man dann am Spieltag nicht seine Leistungsspitze erreicht? Hättest du das für realistisch?
Nein, halte ich nicht für realistisch. Halte ich nicht für realistisch, weil die Spieler sehr sensibel sind und du eben in einer Mannschaft, der eine gewisse Struktur hast, in der auch bei Gladbach und auch bei Hertha Spieler sind, die nun eben schon bestimmt zehn, zwölf Jahre in diesem Geschäft tätig sind, und die ja auch ein Gefühl für das Ganze haben. Und sollte es jemals zu der Situation kommen, dass die Spieler das Gefühl bekommen, wir werden überlastet, dann wird da ganz schnell auch der Finger gehoben und tendenziell ist es eh meines Erachtens im Fußball so, dass eher mal weniger gemacht wird, als mehr. Das ist jetzt überhaupt nicht negativ gemeint, sondern ich glaube das nicht. Nein und ich finde das auch nicht in Ordnung, wenn Leute aus der Ferne Trainingsmethoden bzw. solche Thesen aufstellen, weil wir sind nicht dabei, wir sind nicht annähernd dabei und vor allen Dingen, wenn du in der Türkei oder in China oder sonst wo bist, erst recht nicht. Du weißt nicht, was da täglich passiert und deswegen finde ich das nicht in Ordnung und würde ich auch nie machen.
Ja, es ist ein schwieriges Thema vor allem immer, wenn Antworten zu einfach sind, dann werde ich so ein bisschen hellhörig, weil meine Erfahrung ist, je tiefer man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt und das muss jetzt nicht der Fußball sein, es kann auch jedes andere Thema sein, in der Regel sind die Antworten auf Probleme nie einfach und wenn dann jemand sagt, die spielen deswegen eine schlechte Rückrunde, weil sie falsch trainieren oder weil sie nicht fit sind, dann werde ich allein schon deswegen hellhörig, weil ich mir das nicht vorstellen kann, weil das wäre auch eine Stellschraube, an der zu leicht zu drehen gewesen wäre.
Ja, und wir reden ja auch hier von Vereinen, die jetzt nun Traditionsvereine der Bundesliga sind, die auch Trainer haben, die schon länger in dem Geschäft tätig sind, die erfolgreich waren.
Tradition schützt vor Inkompetenz.
Nee, das stimmt, das ist richtig, aber es sind ja trotzdem Bundesligisten, die jetzt dauerhaft, sage ich mal, in der ersten deutschen Bundesliga spielen. Und das schaffst du jetzt ja nur, wenn du auch eine gewisse regelmäßige, gewisse Konstanz auch hast und solltest du jetzt da in den Bereichen so extrem abfallen, dann kannst du es ja auch irgendwann nicht mehr halten und das ist ja nicht der Fall. Ich glaube, dass die Spieler alle ein gutes Grundniveau haben und es gibt kein falsches Training. Ist einfach so, es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, aber es gibt kein richtig und kein falsch. Sondern da muss jeder meines Erachtens seinen Weg finden und er muss begründen können. Ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig, dass man selber als Athletiktrainer auch vor allen Dingen sagen kann, okay, das ist mein Weg, dazu stehe ich, ich sehe das so und so. Und wenn dann eben beispielsweise ein Trainer sagt, okay, das sehe ich anders, das ist nicht meine Philosophie, da kann ich nicht mit eingehen, dann ist es okay, das ist aber auch überhaupt nicht schlimm. Aber dann passt es halt eben nicht und deswegen gehen ja dann doch auch die Trainerteams oft gemeinsam irgendwo hin, weil man eben sich ja angepasst hat, ne. Oft hat man sich im Jugendbereich kennengelernt und hat dann womöglich die erste Mannschaft übernommen und so wächst das ja dann zusammen, die Abläufe passen und dann geht man eben gemeinsam woanders hin. So, das ist ein normaler Prozess und finde ich auch überhaupt nicht verwerflich. Und dann passt es halt mal, passt es gut in dem Fall und dann gibt es aber sicherlich auch Konstellationen, da passt es halt einfach nicht, aber es ist ja auch okay.
Ja, vor allem, das haben wir ja schon ganz gut rausgearbeitet. Es geht in deinem Bereich und dann eben auch aus Sicht des Cheftrainers geht es so sehr darum, dass man in einem Vertrauensverhältnis mit Vertretern verschiedener Disziplinen zusammenarbeitet, dass es wichtiger sein kann, dass dieses Vertrauensverhältnis auf jeden Fall da ist, also das muss dann nicht bedeuten, wenn ich mit meinem Trainerteam komme, muss das nicht bedeuten, dass diejenigen, die vorher da waren, schlechte Arbeit gemacht hätten, sondern es geht einfach nur darum, ich will mit denen zusammenarbeiten, wo ich weiß, die sagen mir in einer Art und Weise, was Sache ist, was sie denken, mit der ich umgehen kann. Jetzt habe ich noch ein Zitat gefunden bei der Recherche, diesmal von Tim Lobinger, ehemaligen Stabhochspringer, der sich jetzt auch im Bereich der Athletik etablieren möchte, er sagt, Zitat, es ist leider so, Fußballdeutschland ist in der athletischen Betreuung ein Entwicklungsland. Zurzeit gibt es nur wenige Vereine, die systematisch und auf hohem Niveau Athletik trainieren. Eigentlich sind das nur Leipzig, Hoffenheim und Dortmund. Ist Deutschland ein Athletik-Entwicklungsland?
Es ist sehr viel Potenzial noch da in vielen Vereinen.
Also ein entschiedenes Jein von deiner Seite.
Ja, ich glaube, dass in dem Fall natürlich mit dem Lobinger ein ehemaliger Leichtathlet spricht, der das ja auch sein Leben lang betrieben hat und eben auch weiß, wie wichtig das ist. Und für jemanden, der damit aufgewachsen ist, ist es natürlich deutlich schwieriger nachzuvollziehen als für jemanden, der jetzt beispielsweise im Fußball groß geworden ist und damit nie wirklich konfrontiert worden ist. Das heißt, dass es eben gerade im Spielsport, speziell aber eben im Fußball, einfach auch keine Normalität ist, dass Athletiktraining auch schon im Jugendbereich, vor allen Dingen aber auch im Amateurbereich, wir reden jetzt ja dann eben auch von kleineren Vereinen, Dorfvereinen, die ja wichtig sind für die Basis, die sich aber eben auch aus finanzieller Sicht das ja gar nicht leisten können, dass das eben dort keine Normalität ist. Und natürlich fehlt uns dann hinten raus oder mittelfristig einfach da eine gewisse Qualität. Das ist sicherlich auch in anderen Ländern anders, wie ich schon sagte. Ich glaube, in Amerika ist es einfach in der Kultur verankert. In Australien ist es eben auch so, dass Athletik, Fitness in allen Sportarten irgendwie dazu gehört. Und das ist eben in Deutschland vielleicht lange nicht so gewesen. Und dafür brauchen wir sicherlich auch noch ein paar Jährchen, um da eben auch weiter zu kommen. Deswegen ist es Potenzial da, aber es ist nicht so, dass es nicht erkannt wird.
Okay, und das finde ich im Breitensport und im Amateursport kann ich das sehr gut nachvollziehen. Wenn er jetzt aber sagt, dass es nur Leipzig, Hoffenheim und Dortmund gäbe, die auf hohem Niveau Athletik trainieren, dann spricht er ja schon von der höchsten Leistungsspitze, also sprich vom Profifußball. Gehst du da auch mit seiner Einschätzung mit, dass es auch da noch so viel Potenzial gibt, was gehoben werden kann?
Also ich glaube, dass die Vereine, was das angeht, sehr gut aufgestellt sind und da Vorreiter sind. Ja, das glaube ich schon. Und dass das eben auch erstrebenswert ist für die Vereine, die jetzt, sag ich mal, im Hintergrund oder hinten anstehen.
Und was machen die da anders? Geht es da vor allem um Kapazitäten und Personal?
Ich denke, es geht vor allen Dingen um Personal. Ich glaube, das ist entscheidend. Ich habe ja nun auch jahrelang alleine den Jugendbereich bei uns beim FC Ingolstadt gemacht und das ist ja am Anfang, machst du das ja auch gerne und es macht dir Spaß, aber du willst ja irgendwann auch weiterkommen, du willst ja auch mehr Qualität reinbringen, willst die Quantität verringern, die Qualität erhöhen und das geht natürlich nur mit Personal und dafür muss aber eben auch das Auge und vor allen Dingen auch ja die Gewissheit bei den entsprechenden Leuten im Verein da sein, dass das wichtig ist und ich glaube, dass das die Vereine, die du gerade genannt hast, dass das dort der Fall ist, dass sie eben für ihre Bereiche Experten engagiert haben und dass du so natürlich eben dann auch die Qualität in dem Training erhöhen kannst oder erhöht hast und das ist eine finanzielle Geschichte auch, muss man auch klar sagen und ja, es ist ja strebenswert da mal hinzukommen, ja auch für so einen Verein sicherlich wie uns, wobei ich sagen muss, dass sich das eben schon stetig entwickelt hat und das wird sich sicherlich in den anderen Vereinen auch noch tun, aber es ist Es ist ein langjähriger Prozess, ist leider so.
Ja, vor allem ist es ja auch eine Abwägungsentscheidung. Also wenn ich derjenige bin, der dann den Etat eines Bundesligisten verwaltet, dann sehe ich natürlich schon die Möglichkeit, dass ich jetzt da nochmal einen Betrag in Aufstockung des Trainerstabs stecke. Ich werde aber daran gemessen, wie wir in dieser Saison in unserer Liga abschneiden. Und da könnte es für mich kurzfristig schlauer sein, für mich ganz persönlich, jetzt einfach diesen Betrag in das Gehalt eines Spielers zu stecken, den ich halten möchte oder XY.
Der Mehrwert, den du dann hast, den siehst du ja erstmal nicht. Wer weiß, ob du den überhaupt siehst. Das ist ja die Sache, wenn du etwas regelmäßig machst, beispielsweise ein Präventionstraining, dann werden wahrscheinlich gewisse Thematiken gar nicht entstehen, weil du ja regelmäßig das machst. Von daher kannst du ja dann auch irgendwann die Frage stellen, gut bringt mir das jetzt was? Du wirst es dann erst wissen, wenn du es dann nicht mehr machst. Und das ist eben der Bereich Athletik, Ernährung, Mentalität, das sind eben die Bereiche, die so nicht greifbar sind. Da tun sich natürlich viele Vereine dann auch schwer, da zu investieren, gerade auch im Jugendbereich, weil ob ich jetzt, ob der Spieler XY in der U13, U14 irgendwann mal bei den Profis ankommt, das weiß ja keiner. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr gering, ist einfach so. Aber trotzdem investierst du jetzt in die Manpower, du erhoffst dir, dass das passiert, aber du wirst es nie wissen, das ist nicht greifbar und das ist natürlich im Profibereich, wenn du dann die Möglichkeit hast, einen Spieler XY für die Summe zu bekommen, du weißt, der hat die Qualität und der wird dich jetzt wahrscheinlich kurzfristig weiterbringen, dann werden sie es wahrscheinlich machen und dann wirst du auch kurzfristig den Erfolg eventuell eher einfahren, als wenn du jetzt in die Manpower investierst und das über Jahre dauert. Das ist ja dieser Zwiespall, den halt viele haben und dafür brauchst du eben aber meines Erachtens auch Leute, die das erkennen. Und es gab ja gerade die Geschichte mit Max Eberl, dass er sich entschieden hat, den Vertrag von Dieter Hecking aufzulösen. Ich kenne ja jetzt keine Hintergründe und so weiter, aber ich finde, da sieht man schon, dass der Max Eberl einfach jemand ist, der strategisch denkt, der vorausstaunt denkt. Und das finde ich toll, dass es solche Leute gibt, die jetzt nicht nur die Kurzfristigkeit sehen, sondern die eben auch mittelfristig bis langfristig denken, was könnte uns gut tun. Obwohl das ja eine sehr erfolgreiche Phase gerade war oder ist auch für Gladbach, wenn sie dann letztendlich auch vielleicht hoffentlich in die Champions League kommen.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich und gleichzeitig sollte das jetzt aber schief gehen. Und sportlich wird in der nächsten Saison alles ganz fürchterlich laufen für Gladbach, egal in welcher Konstellation. Dann wird niemand Max Eberl für seine Strategie loben und ich habe auch noch nicht das Lob auf Christian Heidel gehört, der in Schalke riesige Investitionen umgesetzt hat. Ich glaube, die waren vorher schon geplant, aber er war dann an der Umsetzung beteiligt, was so Trainingsinfrastruktur angeht. Also du hörst ganz, ganz selten bei der Bewertung von denjenigen, die Entscheider sind im Fußball. Der hat aber wirklich gute Strukturen geschaffen oder der hat in dem Bereich nochmal ein Fokus gelegt und auch deshalb haben wir jetzt diese goldenen Generationen an Fußballern fünf Jahre später. So funktioniert halt irgendwie auch der Fußball nicht. Okay, wenn wir aber unromantisch sind, stelle ich eine letzte romantische Frage dann wenigstens. Gibt es Spieler, die sich vielleicht auch später nochmal bei dir gemeldet haben und gesagt haben, Jan, was du damals mit mir gemacht hast, also das, was wir gehört haben im Intro von Thomas Müller, der zu Andreas Kornmayer, seinem Fitness-Trainer, damaligen Fitness-Trainer, sagt, du hast aus einer langsam Schnecke eine schnelle Schnecke gemacht.
Ja, also es gibt schon Spieler, die gerade im Jugendbereich mich danach angerufen haben oder sich später gemeldet haben und gesagt haben, Mensch, Jan, das, was wir damals bei dir gemacht haben, es hat mir gefallen, ich würde das auch gerne machen, in die Richtung gehen. Kannst du mir mal einen Tipp geben und das sind für mich eigentlich die schönsten Anrufe bzw. der schönste Mehrwert auch aus der Sache, wenn ich jungen Menschen in dem Fall dann auch helfen konnte, eventuell dann ihren beruflichen Weg zu finden. Das ergibt einen schon ein sehr schönes Gefühl und ja, das hatte ich und ich denke auch, dass es vielleicht das ein oder andere noch passieren wird.
Ach, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr hättet sehen sollen, wie jetzt die Augen gerade geleuchtet haben von Jan. Ich glaube, da wird wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich fühle ich in zehn Jahren ein Tribünengespräch und dann sagt jemand, ja, und dann hatte ich ja einen Mentor und das war der Jan-Philipp Hestermann damals bei Ingolstadt, das war und deswegen bin ich jetzt die Chorephäe in diesem Bereich geworden. Jan, ich danke dir sehr herzlich, das hat großen Spaß gemacht mit dir, über deinen Job zu sprechen und da mal ein bisschen mehr zu lernen. Es geht in diesen Tribünengesprächen immer darum, erst mal Dinge halbwegs zu verstehen.
Vielen Dank, Max, hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, und danke und Grüße an dieser Stelle dann an Ralf Gunnisch. Mal gucken, ob er dieses Tribünengespräch hören wird. Er hat uns beide zusammengeführt und das Tribünengespräch mit ihm. War der Anlass dafür, dass wir uns hier kennengelernt haben. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und hört natürlich auch in unseren anderen Formate. Nicht nur, wenn ihr Ralf Gunnisch heißt. Grüße. Mal gucken, ob er das hier gehört hat an der Stelle. Es gibt noch den Kurzpass und die Schlusskonferenz. Bis bald im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.